放就好了
这边往这边放
这个瓦特了
来我来量一量
你们谁要放实力吧
来
胸围胸围
94 98 94 98
腰围86 90
86 90
臀围100
来
长度长度97
群长97
来这个群谁要19
19扣2
能接受的几扣
19扣个2
来来来
来这一款来这边
大家帮我们看一下这个
来腰后面带松紧腰
前面有一排装饰扣
来面料锯纸的
来来来我来量一下你们听一下
腰围66
可以拉伸到86
臀围
臀围142146
来裙长77
裙长77
来这个裙子谁要谁来扣
2929扣个2
29扣个2
谁要谁来扣扣个2
来喜欢的姐姐去扣
哇这个裙
脱色的a字裙
脱色a字裙
后面有隐形拉链
后面有隐形拉链呢
来腰围70 72
臀围
腿围126130
裙长68
拉这个裙子谁要谁来扣
来来来1919扣3
19扣个3
19扣个3哦
来这一款卡吉达
来来来1919扣3 19扣个3喔
色的来卡机色的这个全单层单层1919
这个也蛮好看的
来灰色的
能穿就这个天穿了这个后这个后
这个后
来
我感觉我卖错价了
这个感觉
应该要卖29的不管了
都给啊那个也给是吗红色也要是不是
都是夏天可以穿的297
春夏秋我觉得都可以穿啊
来这个297
灰色
这灰色39
这灰色会怎么
你贴着标呢
1万多的
给你看看啊
1万多的这个啊
29这个这个牌子
这个牌子的
m码人棉毛巨指这个秋冬款啊
吊牌价是13000多
13000多然后12000这个这个是29
29也是个a字群给你量一下
啊灰色我买的49真的
这个29
来腰围的话6466
腿围126128126128
长度的话6629
可以吗
这个款这两天我都没看到
小了小了就过好吧
这个是m的上面写的是m
人棉毛巨指
我买的那个是l啊ok
来这个谁要29扣个2那个长吗
那个是不是比这个要长
这个也是个贵货
吊牌价是哇塞
20900的
来这一款20900
吊牌价看是19000本体什么19000
看到了没有20900的
来这个是一码
一码毛泥的
毛泥的这个群
贵货贵货
来这款毛泥a字群后面有隐形拉链的
来这款咱们来量一下你听一下这款
来
腰围腰围60
可以拉到72
腿围140
来群长78
群长78
来这个是一码有点小了算了给大家39吧好吧
39谁要
谁扣3
两万多的
两万多的说实话最少都得要卖
七八十的
最少都得要卖八十多的这个
你们谁要谁就扣吧
算了算了卖了算了
能穿的姐姐就扣啊这个是
一码这个是小的
来这一款来给萌们看下直统群
直统裙面料锯纸的
来左边有风机扣有拉链有风机扣有拉链来直统直统呢
来保温保温
腰围
来头在天空
腰柱
腰围
腰彰
为六十六十二六十六十二
存为九十六一零二
九十六一零二
来群场九十六群场
九十六来这款谁要
九块九块扣七
九块九块扣七扣七
来谁要谁来扣
九块九块扣七
扣七来谁要
谁来扣九块扣七
来这个格子裙
腰后面是松紧腰的
包臀的底下
鱼尾咔嗝咔嗝
来给宝宝们看一下这款
腰围腰围六十六
可以拉伸到
八十二臀围
一百可以拉到一零二
来群场
七十三群场七十三
来这个裙子谁要
谁来扣十九十九扣一
十九扣一
来喜欢的姐姐就扣十九扣
五个一
这两个群我都放一下
两个群都放一下
来前面直伸后面鱼尾
来卡吉色腰是松紧腰
前面直伸后面鱼尾
来这一款裙
腰围腰围六十四八十八
六十四八十八
腰围一百
腰围一百腰围一百
来长度
前面是八十三后面是八十六
来这款谁要
谁来扣二十九二十九
扣个六二十九扣六
二十九扣六
来来这款来给帮我们看一下这款后面有隐形拉链的来这一个啊这个是一个西装面料的一个条纹的直动裙后面底边开个扇腰围六十四六十六腿围九十二九十四九十二九十四来全场五十五来谁要谁来估九块五十五uyualluyuoyuoyuyuoyuyuyuyuyuyuoyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuiyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuoyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuoyuyuoyuyuoyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuoyyuyuyuyuyuoyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyuoyyuyuyuyuyuyuyuyyuoyuyuyuyuyuyuyyuyuyuyuy
9块
扣3扣3
谁要谁来扣9块扣3
来这一款来给我们看一下
上面包腿底下鱼尾
后面有隐形拉链的
来面料锯纸
面料锯纸
来腰尾64
64可以拉到78
来腿尾
92可以拉到98
92 98
来长度91
来这款谁要
29 29
扣1扣1
来喜欢的姐姐就扣29扣1
来来来
来这一款来给我们看
戴帽子的夹两件
戴帽子夹两件
左边戴刺绣字母的
后背是有这个字母
来这一款这款夹两件
夹两件
来这款咱们来量一下
胸围104110
来长度66
长度66
来谁要9块9块扣6
短袖短袖
谁要谁来给我9块扣6
9块扣6
来130130的
来家里有孩子能穿的
这个9块9块
9块扣1
来蓝色的这个直筒裙
牌子标剪掉了
这是个九码
九码这个应该是棉的
这个是棉的
标上面啥也没写
但是我摸着这个是棉的啊
全棉的
来直筒裙
蓝格子蓝格子春秋款
春秋款春秋款
胸围
胸围九十二九十八
九十二九十八
腰围八十八九十二
八十八九十二
来臀围九十八一零六
九十八一零六
来长度长度九十一
来长度九十一
来这个裙子谁要三十九三十九
抠个三
三十九
谁要谁来抠个三
三十九抠三
全棉全棉姐妹们啊
全棉全棉
三十九抠三
来这个吊带来给帮我们看一下
面料锯纸
前面有拉链
后面是带松拧的有腰带
有松拧的有腰带
来这块
tung Pfizer 效果
面料锯纸
来
胸围106可以拉到116
来腰围94 98 94 98
来长度长度57
来这一款谁要29 29扣7
29扣7
来这一款来给访问看一下
直等裤直等裤
来这个蓝色的
M码人年33
矩指63
矩码是4%
M码M码直等裤
这个蓝色
腰是松紧腰
来腰围66
腰围66可以拉到88
来
来盆围100 108
100 108
来当长35
当长35
来裤长95
裤长95
来这个裤子谁要谁来扣
来29